we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question we got from the
rare female caller to the voicemail line
hi David
I was wondering about your viewer
demographics I've noticed that a great
majority of your callers both voicemails
and live crawlers are men right I'm
wondering if this is simply because like
women are less likely to call in or if a
majority of your viewers are men and if
most of them are I mean why do you think
this is yeah thank you so listen I don't
know if female audience members are more
or less likely to call than male
audience members what I do know is that
our show and every show like this The
Young Turks secular talk the majority
report with sam cedar all these shows
have disproportionately male audiences I
don't know what the answer is I could
speculate that men more than women watch
political talk shows that are
disproportionately on the Internet I
think that from the emails we get our
radio audience is much more evenly split
between men and women but there is no
question that our online our podcast and
YouTube audiences are overwhelmingly
male and it is something that we
actually have more female listeners
based on the demographic data that that
we get then most of the other shows I
mentioned by a little bit not not by a
lot and I don't know why that is it may
be the story choice it may be something
else I don't know but yeah our show and
others like it are significantly more
than 50% male audiences probably fair to
say that men in general are more into
politics than women really I think you
can back that up by looking at you know
what people major in in college let me
take a political science major the vast
majority of people in that major are men
about you know that word a fact yeah
and the vast majority of people watching
the show or male - so maybe you have
something to do with that Wow
I don't know about the truth of anything
Pat just said but assuming all of the
underlying assertions are accurate and
the data is accurate your conclusion may
be one that I could get behind so I'd
like is that enough caveat since I have
no idea for sure but yeah but you have
to protect yourself right you have to
have all the grounds covered and
understand why you did that but I think
it's a fair point that I'm a knowing
nothing at all about the underlying data
Pat's referencing his conclusions on the
basis of that data being true sound more
or less precise to me as is what I think
I will say great bonus show today I
don't have time to tell you about it
other than you can get the bonus show by
either being a member or a patron I'll
speak to you then